si lo que se sabe hasta ahora es un
hombre que se difundió fernando andrés a
back montiel
es un ciudadano brasileño por lo menos
es ciudadano brasileño a pesar de que
han circulado vídeos en los que aparece
algo aleatorio en notas periodísticas
hechas en la calle los canales
descripción esas notas consideran que es
la misma persona y habla con un español
muy muy argentino así que eso no no está
del todo claro es una persona de 35 años
hay cierta información de que tiene
algún tipo de antecedentes por algún
tipo de portación de armas y no hay
muchísima más información la información
clave lo que más interesa y que está en
el marco de la investigación y que
esperemos que en algún momento se
conozca es el motivo que llevó a esta
persona a este señor a acercarse de este
modo a la vicepresidenta e intentar
gatillar este arma para pillar este arma
según dijo el presidente alberto
fernández es que este tiro no saliera
esa es la gran pregunta que todos se
están haciendo aquí ahora en argentina
lo que se espera es al mediodía hay una
mar convocada en el obelisco que es el
epicentro de la ciudad de buenos aires
por el frente de todos la coalición de
gobierno en respaldo a la vicepresidenta
en repudio a este intento de atentado
contra su vida que va a marchar a la
plaza de mayo como vivo el mediodía de
argentina esa es una movilización
también había una discusión que se
estaba saltando en la azotea que es una
central obrera y la cgt que es otra
central obrera para ver si además se
lleva adelante una suerte de paro
nacional en el marco de de este día
feriado para dar también su respaldo a
la vicepresidenta